Speaker 1: This is also a bit of good news. The
Department of Justice is finally going to start
a formal investigation into Donald Trump's 15
boxes of records that he had secreted away at
Mar a Lago before they were turned over to the
National Archives, The Washington Post reporting
the Justice Department has begun taking steps
to launch an investigation into former President
Donald Trump's improper removal of presidential
records to Mar a Lago, some of which were labeled
top secret. Remember, we couldn't vote for
Hillary, or we shouldn't because she couldn't
be trusted with secret information. Trump's
flushing documents, incinerating documents,
eating documents, hiding, hiding away documents at
Mar a Lago. The people who spoke on the condition
of anonymity to discuss an ongoing investigation
said the probe remained in the early stages.
It's not yet clear if the Justice Department
officials have started reviewing the materials
in the boxes, or if they are seeking to interview
those who might have seen them or been involved
in assembling and moving them. The news comes
as the department faces increasing political
pressure to disclose its plans. On Thursday, House
Oversight Chairwoman Carolyn Maloney, Democrat
from New York, accused the Justice Department
of obstructing her committee's investigation
into the 15 boxes of records that Trump took with
him. So, number one, it's about time. Number two,
this is nothing other than step like zero point
one, but at least it's something and we'll see if
and where it goes anywhere. And then again,
I mean, we I gave you some of these numbers
during previous investigations into Trump with
Watergate. It was 783 days from the break in to
Nixon's resignation. And even then, it was only
that quick because Nixon resigned. Here we have
a situation where Trump is no longer
president and we are only in the early stages.
It could be a very, very long time. Iran-Contra,
from Reagan announcing the investigation to
the end of the congressional investigation
was two hundred and fifty four days. These things
do take a long time. I don't have high hopes. I
don't believe Trump is going to do a day in
prison. You guys already know. I think that.
But it does look that, you know, even in the best
cases where something provably wrong was done,
it still takes a really long time. Merrick Garland
got to get his act together. And as a reminder,
Joe Biden should have nothing to do with this
and he's not getting involved. That's the correct
thing, as we spoke about yesterday. Joe Biden
should do nothing to encourage or interfere
with an investigation into Hunter Biden. Joe Biden
should do nothing to interfere with or encourage
an investigation into anything that Donald
Trump has done. But the Justice Department
is starting, and that's good news, and it will
likely mean more legal fees for Donald Trump.